[Musik]
Geschwindigkeitsrekord in Indianapolis
es sieht aus wie ein Formel 1 Rennen
aber es ist Wissenschaft am
limits of driving am Steuer sitzt kein
Mensch sondern künstliche Intelligenz
bei diesem Rennen geht es nicht um PS
sondern um den besten Algorithmus
[Musik]
16 junge Wissenschaftler der Technischen
Universität München angeführt von
Ingenieur und uniprof Markus lienkamp
zwei Jahre haben sie sich auf das große
Rennen vorbereitet es geht gegen 24
Teams aus der ganzen Welt in
Indianapolis werden die Grenzen des
autonomen Fahrens getestet und
verschoben
diese Limits zur händeln
bei Höchstgeschwindigkeit
hier geht es um die Grenzen des Alltags
über 7.000 km entfernt ein kleiner
regionalflugplatz bei Chemnitz Edgar ist
ein Versuchsfahrzeug der TU München
vollgepackt mit allem was das autonome
Auto der Zukunft vielleicht einmal
braucht wir haben verschiedene
Kameratypen die können wir hier sehen
Stereo Kameras Weitwinkel telekameras
wir haben lesersensoren um quasi das
komplette Fahrzeug Umfeld anzuschauen
wir haben in der Mitte noch mal einen
Lasersensor der sehr weit nach vorne
gucken kann wir über 200 Meter richtig
äh Sichtweite und zusätzlich noch an der
Fahrzeugfront verbaut verschiedene Radar
Typen mit denen wir auch noch unsere
ganzen
fahrzeugteilnehmer erkennen können und
eine Spezialität hier auch noch ähm
Mikrofone für den außenschall mit denen
wir auf zum Beispiel Krankenwagen von
außen schon vorher erkennen können bevor
der Fahrer das hören kann so sieht die
Zukunftsvision aus
Infos die den Fahrer nicht nur
unterstützen sondern das Fahren gleich
selbst übernehmen und nicht nur das das
Auto muss sich im Straßenverkehr
verhalten wie ein Mensch mit all seinen
Sinnen und Reflexen Thomas Fritsche und
sein Team wollen Edgar genau das
beibringen
die große Herausforderung ist im
alltäglichen öffentlichen Verkehr klar
zu kommen da muss man mit einem rechnen
das können Fahrradfahrer sein die einem
die Spur kreuzen das können andere
Verkehrsteilnehmer sein und insbesondere
sind diejenigen Verkehrsteilnehmer die
die Regeln Verkehrsregeln nicht so gut
kennen weil wir trainieren unseren
Fahrzeug natürlich die Verkehrsregeln an
all das bedeutet einen enormen
Entwicklungsaufwand die Hersteller
investieren viele Milliarden in ihre
Systeme für sie ist das selbstfahrende
Auto das kommende Geschäftsmodell
experten rechnen mit Gewinnen von bis zu
400 Milliarden Dollar im Jahr weltweit
in Deutschland kommt die S-Klasse von
Mercedes dem autonomen fahren bislang am
nächsten im sogenannten Level 3 kann der
fahrende auch auf der Autobahn die Hände
vom Steuern nehmen
sie müssen jeden Morgen eine Stunde zu
ihrer Arbeit pendeln und sie könnten in
Zukunft diese eine Stunde die Zeit
nutzen um etwas anderes zu als Auto zu
fahren und vielleicht noch zu
telefonieren nämlich die E-Mail schon
bearbeiten vielleicht auch einfach nur
einen Film schauen oder etwas anderes im
Fahrzeug tun wir haben uns das
angeschaut und da gibt es eine sehr hohe
Zahlungsbereitschaft des Individuums das
eben diese eine Stunde und vielleicht
sind es dann sogar zwei Stunden am Tag
wenn man hin und zurück pendelt
Lebenszeit zu gewinnen und das ist ein
Faktor warum wir der Meinung sind dass
das der Markt für autonomes fahren sehr
sehr stark ansteigen wird dieser Markt
ist hart umkämpft die Chefs von BMW
Mercedes oder VW müssen sich gegen
starke Konkurrenz aus den USA und vor
allem China behaupten die deutschen
sahen sich immer als Trendsetter heute
treten sie gegen Wettbewerber an für die
ein Auto nicht mehr ist als eine
Softwareplattform und der Autopilot so
normal wie ein Update wer hat die Nase
vorn die Konzepte könnten kaum
unterschiedlicher sein
eine Direktorin des chinesischen
Konzerns Huawei Deutschland sieht im
Auto der Zukunft ein Smartphone auf
Rädern
different devices das Auto muss mit
verschiedensten Geräten verbunden sein
SmartWatch Smartphone und den Geräten zu
Hause und der Wechsel zwischen den
Geräten muss nahtlos sein ziemliches
Oliver Zipse erklärt das kurze Hand zur
Schnapsidee die Menschen wollten gerade
kein iPhone auf Rädern sondern vielmehr
deutsche Präzision es ist nicht darum
wer den größten Bildschirm hat es geht
auch nicht darum wer die größte
Rechenleistung im Fahrzeug hat sondern
wer am effizientesten mit der Rest
umgehst was ganz anderes Auto Papst
Ferdinand Dudenhöffer warnt die
deutschen Hersteller man solle die
Chinesen nicht unterschätzen
sie sind einfach schneller wie wir die
sind dynamischer und die nehmen auch
größere Risiken gekauft in China ist es
eben so dass wenn staatlich vorgegeben
wird dass ein Erlaubnis gegeben wird
weil man glaubt man kann damit die
technischen Vorsprung erreichen dann
macht man das in China und das Risiko
ist groß dass die einem dann auf der
Nase
im Gegenteil sagt der Verband der
deutschen autom die Industrie hier ist
man sich sicher wir können auf jeden
Fall mithalten und ich glaube wir
sollten auch nicht den Eindruck immer
wiederholen dass die Amerikaner oder
Chinesen oder andere weiter sind als wir
hier das ist oftmals auch deutsche
Technologie die auf diesen Märkten auch
schon erprobt wird und das ist der
entscheidende Punkt die Technik und die
Ideen haben wir wir müssen Sie auch hier
erproben genau das ist es was die
Wissenschaftler hier in Chemnitz
regelmäßig tun heute auf dem Programm
eine Art Fahrsicherheitstraining nicht
für den Fahrer sondern für das Auto wir
probieren gerade wie wir mit erhöhter
Geschwindigkeit trotzdem unseren
lenkwehen gehalten können das heißt das
Fahrzeug nicht zu schnell lenkt und das
Fahrzeug dann quasi zum Ausbrechen
neigen würde das Applizieren wir heute
wir stellen unsere Werte ein die dann
fest ins Fahrzeug auch kodiert werden
Gründlichkeit und Sicherheit darum geht
es nicht nur in Chemnitz sondern auch
bei den Kollegen am Lehrstuhl für
Automobiltechnik an der TU München
hier wird daran geforscht dem Fahrzeug
beizubringen gefährliche Situationen im
Straßenverkehr zu erkennen die
Herausforderung auf algorithmischer
Seite ist aktuell dass wir sehr sehr
viele Daten haben wo wir beispielsweise
unsere ki-basierten Algorithmen
trainieren können und optimieren können
aber diese ki-basierten Algorithmen dann
nur auf diesen Daten sehr gut sind aber
auf einzelnen sogenannten Edge cases
also Szenarien die nur sehr sehr selten
passieren aber unter Umständen sehr
kritisch sind die abzubilden in diesem
großen Datenpool ist ja schwierig
autonomes fahren braucht also künstliche
Intelligenz aber nur wenn diese
verlässlich arbeitet wird sie auch vom
Menschen akzeptiert und gekauft
Gitter ist Professorin und codirektorin
der Konrad Zuse School für verlässliche
künstliche Intelligenz autonomes fahren
hat für sie einen wichtigen ethischen
Aspekt also stellen wir uns zum Beispiel
vor man fährt eine Straße schlank und es
ist eine Unfallsituation auf der einen
Seite ist vielleicht eine
ältere Dame auf der anderen Seite ein
Kind und man muss entscheiden und man
kann nur in eine Richtung fahren ein
Mensch wird dann sehr intuitiv
entscheiden aber bei einem autonomen
Auto ist es völlig anders denn ein
autonomes Auto prognostiziert 10
Sekunden in die Zukunft und muss
sozusagen diese Entscheidung dann ich
sage mal rational treffen das heißt muss
in das Auto hart codieren in welche
Richtung jetzt gefahren wird ich denke
hier hat die deutsche Gründlichkeit
schon ein extrem Vorteil weil natürlich
gerade bei dem autonomen fahren
Zuverlässigkeit extrem wichtig ist auch
zum Beispiel um Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung zu bekommen
robotaxis die wie hier ohne Fahrer durch
chinesische Großstädte fahren sind bei
uns noch weit von einer Zulassung
entfernt das entscheidende
Verkaufsargument für autonome Systeme
ist die Verlässlichkeit der Technik
davon sind längst noch nicht alle
Menschen überzeugt während sich 60% der
Chinesen für ein selbstfahrendes Auto
entscheiden würden sind dies in den USA
57% in Deutschland würden sich nur 36%
dafür entscheiden
die Skepsis ist nicht unbegründet denn
künstliche Intelligenz kommt durchaus an
ihre Grenzen an solchen Szenarien
arbeitet das Team um Frank Diermeier von
der TU München was wenn das autonome
Auto in einen unfallgerät und auf die
Gegenfahrbahn ausweichen muss eigentlich
ein klarer Regelverstoß hier braucht es
wieder den Menschen wir können aus der
Ferne genau diese Situationen
unterstützen und helfen indem wir zum
Beispiel weitere Regeln freigeben zum
Beispiel dass es auf die Gegenspur
fahren darf das ist über durchgezogene
Linien fahren darf oder vielleicht auch
mal wenn es gar nicht anders geht auch
mal über einen Fahrradweg fährt so dass
es dann aber danach wieder in dem
Bereich der Automatisierung ist ist
alleine die Mission dann auch wieder
erfüllen kann Tele operated driving
heißt das im Fachjargon autonomes fahren
hat viele Aspekte und ist immens Komplex
mit Edgar dem hochgerüsteten
Versuchsfahrzeug in Chemnitz will die TU
München nun neue Wege gehen open Sour
Open Access das heißt allen sind die
Daten zugänglich unsere Überlegung ist
dass keiner in der Lage ist alleine das
autonome fahren hinzubekommen es braucht
die Sensorik die rechenplattform den
Automobilhersteller Testfälle und das
muss man alles gemeinsam zusammen
bekommen
wir wollen hier eine Basis und Plattform
aufbauen dass diese Zusammenarbeit
überhaupt möglich ist das ist heute
nicht der Fall und auf dieser Plattform
können dann alle Firmen alle
Forschungspartner zusammen diese
Software gemeinsam entwickeln
Deutschland China USA keiner wird das
autonome fahren am Ende ganz allein
entwickeln es wird sich der Weg
durchsetzen der die besten Ideen vereint
Komfort Bedienbarkeit und Sicherheit das
Rennen ist weiter offen
[Musik]